[Musique]
Amama figure humanitaire et spirituelle
internationale est en visite dans l'île
pour 3 jours dès son plus jeune âge ama
qui est né dans le Kerala vient en aide
à toutes les personnes en souffrance
Amama a connaî la Réunion elle y est
venue de nombreuses fois elle sera dans
le jardin de l'étave ce vendredi pour
des étreintes maternelle appelé darchan
am est connu pour ses étreintes qu'on
appelle un darchan darchan au départ ça
veut dire avoir la vision d'un maître
physique ou de Dieu ou de ce que vous
concevz comme étant l'absolu bon am
vient pour la 24e fois à la Réunion mais
elle vient ici depuis 30 ans au début
pour les 24e enfin les 20e premières
fois ell venaient tous les ans et depuis
vu que ça coûte très cher et que ces
voyages sont de plus en plus longs on
faisait tous les 2 ans et l'année passée
pour des raisons qui étaient en dehors
de
nos propres paramètres elle a pas pu
venir Amama rencontrera la présidente du
conseil départemental ce vendredi avant
de se rendre au jardin de l'État au
jardin de l'État donc à 19h30
rencontrer la présidente à 19h au
palais et puis la journée de samzi qui
va se terminer par le D Baba o rev
l'aspect de la M divine ama a serré dans
ses bras plus de 34 millions de
personnes à travers le monde ils
viendront du monde entier justement pour
la rencontrer à la Réunion plusieurs
délégations composées de 30 nationalités
se retrouveront dans notre île pour
vivre leur instant de paix et
[Musique]
d'amour